I like doing that what like sort of one
or two counts this doesn't it count
security
good evening my name's Andy Crump Eiling
cheering tonight's the planning
committee be strap addition to cancel
the meeting
so the meeting is going to be webcast
and can I ask members the public
counselors offices to make sure their
phones are on silent or switched off
there's nothing worse than the speaker
being in to bond the zones are the great
escape or the floor all down so whatever
songs we have on our phones also any
registered speakers are not allowed to
speak tonight so again please - a tape
from the audience however tempting it
might be please could you bear with us
to introduce the top table Caroline mash
committee administrator Ross chambers
legal services Karen Tate I'm the
planning manager at tonight's meeting my
role is to provide impartial advice to
clarify any planning issues that arise
and to assist members decision taking
and bound by the Royal Town Planning
Institute code of Professional Conduct
planning committee members are not bound
by advice from officers or the
recommendations
Victoria Chataway Senior Planner Sarah
Macpherson Havana thank you very much
when we vaunted my first item on the
agenda which is volunteer absence
from counselor kettle thank you and next
item on the agenda is disclosed of
interest any items disclosures hence the
minerals
thanks mr. chairman I did get a letter
from the from the African which I think
most people have from Jessica yes thank
you yep yeah it's a mild and that's it
yeah and I think it's from Jessica
McCord Communications Manager and it's
to do obviously application number for
the the Petrova's courage site ships to
item three are you happy to come and I
can assign a minutes of the meeting
count on the 20th 29th of July thank you
I'll do that later Caroline and I'd like
to ask if we could move far to number
five which is application nineteen
slices as a 886 actually if you all
ethan farm he phones mr. field change of
use of shirts to cross d2 gym including
creation of parking area and associated
improvements retrospective asked if it
could move back to item four please
thank you the reason for that is there
are no object is here to speak so I was
asking for the committee to give me
authority or to agree that we delegate
this want offices thank you so when
committee resolved to delegate
application number 90 inch nice to 0 0 8
at six not a few are even farm in fans
mister field to offices thank you thank
you Sarah
right well now move on to the old item
for item five now which is application
number 17 s 0 194 slash a few armpits
garages Church three ships announced
their CV 36 demolition of existing
garage and canopy construction of new
building comprised an a1 retail unit at
ground floor with three flats three
times two beds first floor is our
presenter officer Thank You chairman
the site is indicated by the black dot
are shown on this slide and is located
in the ship's Ananse our defined town
center boundary
this slide shows it in slightly more
context the applications like site to be
an outlined in bread as well as being
within the town center boundary also
falls within the conservation area that
line air is indicated in the pink and
the red blocks show listed buildings
within the site so there's a number of
them within close proximity to the site
this is a Google Street View image of
the site the site is clearly seen as is
the garage with the canopy to the front
of it as fronting on to Church Street it
falls on the corner of Church Street and
Telegraph Street you'll also note that
there's a number of cars parked on the
site at the moment I can't confirm that
the site is currently vacant and has
been so for a small amount of time the
vehicles parked there are that there's
no agreement for them to park there no
right for them to specifically be there
so if the site came back into use either
as a garage or as another use or the
applicant chose to enforce them not
being there than that would be the case
going forward this is an aerial photo or
image of the site this
apologies I've got the wrong spelling
for petofi's garage at the bottom there
you can see that in red as I outlined
and see it within the context of its
Town Center boundary you can see the
other commercial uses quite close to the
situs as indicated in the way that
Google does and see its proximity to the
nearest public car park on Telegraph
Street there are also residential
properties close to the site so it's
flats that adjoining the sites the backs
of that car park that you can see to the
rear relates to those flats and then
there's a residential new opposite side
of Telegraph Street and Church Street
this is the proposed the proposal for
the the ground-floor retail space and it
also shows the proposed parking within
the forecourt and the delivery area for
trucks coming in to and from the site in
addition to this which haven't shown on
this drawing there are some proposals to
improve the pedestrian footpath around
the site that's currently walk walk
particularly where it's more technically
for court whereas adjacent to Telegraph
Street and the proposal is to make that
a pavement that would be to an adoptable
standard what's worth noting at this
point is that this scheme has previously
had planning approval and that approval
has now lapse which is why we've now got
this application in front of us to
assess but fundamentally the design
location quantum of development and
amount of parking has not changed from
that previous approval and that as an
officer's view is a significant material
consideration in the assessment of this
application further information this is
that the first floor arrangement which
would include a small amount of
ancillary retail space and then three
apartments again the configuration in
quantum the development here
hasn't changed from the previous
approval
this shows that elevations as church
streets are at the top is the existing
elevation and the photo for context and
then at the bottom is the proposed
street facing elevation again the design
hasn't changed from the previous
approval and then this is the other main
public realm facing elevation on to
Telegraph Street so again the existing
at the top proposed at the bottom and
that the photo there for context these
are the side and rear elevations these
have far less of a public facing view
there's sort of enough that there will
be some elements that you can see but
fundamentally they're surrounded by lots
of buildings you would see far less of
these elevations and then this is the
view from Telegraph street this is the
views taken from adjacent to the
existing pay and display car park to
give you an idea as to the proximity of
that car park to the garage the garage
you can see at the head of the street in
its the shorter white building on the
right-hand side
and then for more context this is
slightly closer to that garage and
you'll see that there's no pavement on
the one side of Telegraph Street which
is an existing situation so anybody that
lives in those flats has to walk out if
they're going to walk out onto the
opposite side of Telegraph Street and
that that's not proposed to be changed
as a result of this proposal parking was
obviously one of the main the main
concerns in in relation to this
application so that's the purpose of
really showing you the parking situation
on its relationship to Telegraph Street
and I just say in summary that planning
consent was previously approved at this
site for the same proposal was presented
here the level of parking and quantum of
development remain as previously
approved and the location of the site in
the context of X crap of its
surroundings have not materially changed
since that scheme was previously
approved the site remains in a mixed
juice
juice scheme in a town center location
just by means of an update I'm afraid on
the update sheet I forgot to add that we
have had five more objections to the
application since the report was
provided these are objections from
people that had previously objected to
the application and they don't raise any
new material considerations that haven't
been reported there is an update sheet
with additional conditions so the REC
the recommendation remains to approved
subject to conditions including those in
the update you thank you thank you come
on I have our first speaker please which
is kind of the poor Tesh from ships and
monster everything cancer - you've got
three minutes so if you press the button
in the middle yep seconds to go yes
please
thank you thank you chips and start our
counsel objected to this planning
application as follows the application
is concrete to the doctored Negra plan
namely policy env3
and core strategy policy cs8 the
applicants proposed parking provision is
wholly inadequate for the proposed a1
and residential use with only one space
per flat and non for customers we
consider the customers popping into the
proposed convenience store would want to
park nearby rather than use to pay and
display telegraph streetcar Park Town
Council's parking serving clearly
demonstrates that there is there is
inadequate nearby on street parking this
contradicts the findings of the
applicant survey which fails to take
into account residents parking permits
on Church Street in turn this race is
concerned that shoppers will park
illegally and hazardous asleep on Church
Street and Telegram Street will park in
the residents reserves places or on
neighboring private land furthermore
there are major safety hazards for
customers who choose to park on the
Telegraph streetcar plot the Town
Council is extremely concerned
the lack of foot bank provision on the
road Southside between the proposed
store and this car park the applicants
response to this issues that the
pedestrians cross over telegraph street
twice to use the foot way on the north
side this foot way is very narrow
between point nine meter and one meter
wide who is difficult for pedestrians to
pass especially if a pushchair
wheelchair or mobility scooter is
involved and will necessitate stepping
into the territory and crossing the road
leav Junction this is considered very
unsatisfactory and dangerous access for
deliveries opposes highway safety issues
the track look for the delivery HGV
shows the vehicle over running the
centerline in the opposing traffic lane
for both the entry and exit maneuvers
if the frontage is blocked by illegally
parked cars the HTV will have no access
to online stopping to unload in the
carriageway so close to the Telegraph
Street Junction and bus stop will be
dangerous for all road users the Town
Council is concerned about the noise
impact for the development in all the
surrounding blind disparities that the
applicants noise assessment does not
refer to the Assembly Rooms dwellings
with two existing supermarkets one of
which is a convenience store and the
other food shop the town center already
has adequate provision of food supplies
32nd thank you
furthermore since the original planning
application for this site flag
permission has been granted by this
committee for supermarket off Camden
Road I feel both retailers and customers
are far more suitable site with parking
on site and better and much safer
accessibility the Terra Council
respectfully request that this
application was denied for the above
reasons Thank You Tessa Tesh any
questions mr. Mill's Lancaster film
thanks mr. chairman um your
neighbourhood plan has it been adopted
yes it has been and it was specifically
in the neighbourhood plan was this
garage means dock referred to
specifically is nothing in contravention
with the policies okay thank you
within part of the conservation area and
you've got list of buildings in the
facility of it opposite I'm assuming
that the previous planning permission
that was given was still extent extent
when your neighborhood plan development
was adopted yes I'm not a security
question I just come back to
neighborhood plan and what usage had you
in the neighborhood plan flat site or it
hasn't been identified specifically yeah
thank you
any more questions you said that the
site was still active as far as planning
when you published your neighborhood
plan is that correct yes right caps
attention thank you very much you're
free to go and grab our next fake places
is mr. Peter Wilson and unless they've
been registered beforehand unfortunately
yeah non-problem you've got three
minutes again mr. Wilson I'll give you a
warning with 30 seconds to go and far
away when you're ready good evening
thank you for your time I'm Peter Wilson
I live with my family just directly
opposite the sites my daughter's cross
the road every day to get on the school
bus there's a school bus and public bus
stop just immediately where you can see
the park bench and there's another one
in the other direction on the other side
who frequently cars to get around those
two buses sometimes parked at the same
time to all sorts of routes including by
that lay-by and so the kids across the
road against traffic having an
unpredictable routes
I've indicating of a subject of that
being redeveloped it's not very
attractive I think many of us look like
a shop that's not the issue I think the
issue is the practicalities of parking
with the specific plans that have been
proposed and also I think a democratic
principle about whether or not we take
into account the neighborhood plan which
has changed since the plan was lost
approved you can see on this side
there's residents parking also available
for two hours for non-residents that's
pretty much always full you can also see
about eight cars always using that at
that full court informally any
development that happens will shift
those eight cars on on sort of roads and
an increase net demand by eight there
are three parking spaces but there are
three to bed flat so there's no net
addition to parking and in fact there's
a net reduction of about a bit when
those cars are kicked off we know what
happens when people nip in and out of
shops and ships turn further down the
road there's a chip shop people park on
the double yellow lines sometimes two
three four cars on the double yellow
lines
a little bit further down so whatever
the theory that people might park in a
car park around the corner across the
road twice they don't do that
empirically what they do is Park
illegally on w other lines or straddling
a road in order just to nip in and out
but if you have enough people nipping in
and out
I can't Park despite for paying for a
residence permit and I think it's also
very bad for road safety this is the
main road between stratford-on-avon and
Oxford I think it's probably the most
built-up a most narrow point and also a
point where you have bus stops for
public and school buses going in both
directions probably on that entire
stretch so that those are the parking
problems I don't think the parking
survey sufficiently took that into
account particularly the net loss of
those eight cars that are currently
informally using that thing the
neighbourhood plan adopted by 87% of
people included the top priority creates
a more vital and functional sense of
with improved pedestrian spacing and
better traffic flows any solution needs
to marry better traffic flows and
parking capacity with pedestrian safety
there are some overload and pressure on
car parking capacity I think there's a
new material fact since you last
considered this 25 different residents
commented on the proposal 23 opposed and
only two supported so it's an opposition
rate of 92% the Town Council have
consistently objected and the applicants
have made no offer no attempt to address
parking concerns I think we'd love a
shot there we just love a shop with
adequate parking provision thank you
but mr. Wilson before you go sorry
no no I'll probably so and any questions
for mr. Wilson I've got a couple but
anybody else any questions no sir
folding no right he's mean and just to
the ants biases I can see where you're
coming from but there's no guarantee
whatever goes on there where this is
this one
whether I'd still be allowed to park
there is it's illegal parking by
sniffing aren't I and I can see what you
come from but I think that point is a
slight but I lost anyway but my point is
that it adds 8 to the demand which will
go elsewhere which which was not taken
into account in any parking survey that
road is always full the residence
parking is not enforced I accidentally
forgot to renew my resident parking
permit I parked happily there illegally
for a month before anyone noticed my
sweet car park and the pavement and
crossing the road I think he mentioned
twice any record of accidents in that
area please let you know I'm sorry I'm
not that I know that counselor I don't
know that I'm afraid I think the point
is simply the people will not use that
however much they theoretically could
they'll do as they do for the chip shop
which is debark illegally opposite yeah
okay thanks very much thank you come on
guys the field
I believe there's a friendly wall and
that does come around quite a lot so
surely I could only say that we forgot
to renew apartment that we weren't
challenged for a month until we realized
so I mean maybe that warden was missing
something it's very rare that on a first
pass I can pass outside my house despite
paying for a residence permit it's
almost it was full please which is Emma
trivet you've got six minutes Anna you
get the same amount of the to effective
so you've got six minutes and far away
even ready and if you're not warning
with 30 seconds on happy to do and if
you could put the speaker on Thank You
chair my name is Emma Trivette and I'm
from WSP I represent Tesco PR the
applicants Tesco are keen to open
unexpressed or on the site to serve
customers in Justin this is a mixture
scheme providing jobs and investment in
a highly sustainable location in line
with national policy which has
previously been approached by both the
council and the highway authority that
we create approximately 20 full and
part-time jobs as well as providing a
new retool service and residential
opportunities this short presentation
will focus on the transport aspects of
the scheme although we will welcome any
other questions planning permission was
granted in July 2014
unfortunately due to the process of
preparing the site and the starting
conditions the developer of the site
Tesco was an unable to build the need
store before the permission expired in
2017 a new application was therefore
being submitted
comprising precisely the same form and
scheme
skill of development has been being
previously proposed and approves the
transport statement submitted in October
2017 was find the site to be completely
accessible by all modes of travel but
stops are conveniently located close to
the site with services running to many
of the surrounding areas on a regular
basis
due to the complex nature of the area
and the size of the retail units a high
proportion of trips are expected to be
made by sit by local residents and
visitors to the time center the local
highway 30 have confirmed that there are
no recorded road traffic accidents
occurred close to the site in the
previous five years in order to further
improve the site's accessibility it is
proposed to amend plates of things that
way adjacent to the site to both
formalize the vehicular access and also
improve the environment for those
walking to the site an independent Road
Safety Orbiter has formally reviewed
those proposals cycle parking will be
provided on the site for those that wish
to travel to the retail unit it is
expected that many of the trips will be
passed by in nature so these will be
already on the network these may be
people visiting on the way home from
work for example many other trips will
be linked by e people that have already
parts in the area to visit neighboring
uses and call it the store as part of
their visit surveys of parking areas
around the site have been carried out by
an independent survey company and they
indicate that there is an average of 18
spaces available in the parking areas
closest to the site during the weekday
and 16 available spaces of on a Saturday
a car parking accumulation exercise has
been undertaken to assess the likely
parking demands generated across the
local area by the
chill unit a maximum level parking
demand fell well below the number of
spaces available in the local area
Clinton or Arby's points listeners
objection regarding local residents
choosing not to park at some locations
on Church Street as there is an
assumption that parked cars may cause an
obstruction is noted oh you're the
survey indicates that some cars did park
in the areas highlighted during the
survey and the survey company did not
report that this led to an impact from
the fee free flow of traffic
furthermore the highway authority did
not research as a concern during the
planning application nor have they
thought to place double yellow lines
applications to prevent parking in
December 2017 the highway authority
concurred with the parking analysis of
the transport statement of considered
sufficient parking supply is available
within a reasonable walking distance of
the site the Highway Authority confirmed
in july 2019 that they about
consultation comments for me and ballots
and for Andrea's no objections to the
proposals please are Harvey also points
to the existing pedestrian provision in
the area as I previously stated the
transport state statements at site that
this proposal will bring improvements
with the inclusion of dropped curb to
provide safe and convenient movement in
the cross Telegraph Street and
resurfacing that way a decent to the
site this is a mixture of scheme
providing jobs and investment which has
previously been approved we we hope we
we hope and that I am sure G with my
explanation on the transport situation
and he agreed that the proposed or will
help meet the day-to-day needs of local
residents the transport can statement
concluded that the impact of the
development is not considered to be
severe our authority in paragraph 32 of
the NPP F there is therefore no rafi no
reason
curfews permission for the development
on highway ground within what within
time I catch something I was indicated
then against the bomb Thank You chairman
good evening
was there any consent consultation with
the ship some parish council that's all
on this has that been I am the transport
consultant is so we don't know I don't
know but I do have some colleagues here
but I'm not sure if I can answer that
question and the whole presentation need
to be hinged around the parking problem
so if I miss something
are there parking facilities on the
actual site itself their proposed to be
three three parking spaces yes there are
three on the site yes yes so the three
that are on the site are for the people
who live on the site one put Mumper
apartment which means that there's no
parking at all for the retail and unit
the spaces aren't allocated one way or
the other
there's provided on the site but where
will the people who've got apartments
there park that they may use those
pieces
I think we've been around this question
was counselor sent about parking and
parking in the car park at the back the
clinic I've got several questions but I
think I'm probably going to throw them
at the wrong person first of all are we
using the same footprint as the existing
building the second consideration is
being in mind
probably the one point that I can pick
up there is regarding the delivery
vehicles and I believe the highway
officer here has suggested a delivery
management plan and and in that the
hours of delivery and things like
switching off the refrigerator units
would be conditioned as part of that of
that plan that can be saved
I think tensor field illness has been in
the update sheet but we can we can
clarify that Billy officers my own
points of clarification about the
conditions but I think if you look at
the environmental health consultation
response there is one of the conditions
21 condition 21 that's the bond come
back if the Tesco van comes to pick up
for delivery where does it go visit I
think four years ago
it's it's as it set right on that plan
so that is a delivery vehicle so we pull
in into the front to the front of the
store and deliver from there and then
pull off again so the delivery area is
to the front three three spaces
so on the left on my left and one back
right and then the parkings driven in
tonight again we cannot see points of
clarification right any further
questions well I know no you're free to
go I'm kinky and curved our next week
net which is gets the Harvey
[Music]
how odd my collegues is forecastle
Harvey I'm not sure carrion
right okay so happy you've got five
minutes if are already became your
children my objection to this
application is based on two grounds
first parking the information presented
in the transport statement is highly
misleading second road safety the impact
of this development will be to cause
pedestrians to walk in our way for lack
of a suitable footpath members of the
committee will have read comments I've
already submitted this site lies in the
only Aryan ship stand we're a residents
parking firm the scheme is an operation
the three streets involved together
provide 73 parking spaces for which 95
permits have already been issued yet the
applicants transport statement fails to
mention the existing pressure on parking
that has led to the introduction of this
scheme why is that an inconvenient truth
doesn't suit the applicants case or an
indication of lack of understanding of
local conditions the applicant relies on
there being adequate parking within
reasonable walking distance photograph
one is taken from the supporting
transport it illustrates the figures are
set out in tables 4 and 5 in that
document it identifies four areas a B C
and D totaling 43 parking spaces where
it suggests cars could park there are
three areas identified further south e F
and H totaling 23 spaces currently
already regularly used for parking
photographed to illustrates the existing
typical use of areas E and F photographs
three is taken from the junction of
Church Street and Stratford Road looking
north
it shows areas a B and C where the
transport statement indicates there are
34 potential car parking spaces
photographs for is taken from the same
location looking so it shows area D and
other nine spaces are supposedly
available photographed 5 illustrates how
in
it would be to park in areas a B and C
if the transport statement suggests
parking on either or both sides of this
road would drastically interfere with
the flow of traffic along the main
arterial road through shiftin photograph
6 does likewise in relation to area a
these photographs demonstrate that the
real availability of the car parking in
the vicinity of the development isn't in
the 66 has claimed in the transport
statement but 23 when it can't has taken
of the 10 vehicles that are routinely to
be found currently parked in the garage
forecourt having parked in the vicinity
the transport statements own figures
demonstrate that there are already
insufficient parking spaces available to
cope with on demand on average weekdays
or on a Saturday in areas e F and H all
the additional cop car parking all the
additional car traffic generated by
these determined who have extreme
difficulty in parking along Church
Street logically this means that greater
use will have to be made of the
Telegraph Street car park that leads me
to my second concern Road Safety
photographs 7 shows Telegraph Street
look looking westwards the trees in the
middle of the photograph signify the
location of the car park the distance of
about 50 meters there is no footpath on
the South southern side of the street
photograph 8 shows the existing footpath
on the north side of Telegraph Street in
contrast with the 2 meter wide footpath
proposed for the development site itself
this undulating footpath varies in width
from 1.2 meters to less than a meter at
the narrows point which the photograph
illustrates this is too narrow for a
mobility scooter user or a parent with
the pushchair
either to pass each other or to pass
another pedestrian without one or the
other being forced into the road yet the
use of this what path is precisely what
is recommend recommended in the pendency
of the transport statement my
conclusions
first that the committee needs to think
very carefully about the real and
predictable consequence of this
development on on street parking in the
vicinity there's potential for
significant traffic congestion in ships
ins of main artery and that this is
reasonably predictable secondly the
provision of a two meter wide pavement
on the south side of Telegraph state is
essential if this can't be provided by
way of the condition it might be
provided by the committee recommending
an allocation of an element of the
community infrastructure levee or it
might be voluntary 30 second chesco as
part of its corporate social
responsibility program Thank You general
Thank You councillor Harvey very
succinctly and within time questions for
the warden under place you mentioned the
Transport statement provided the
Highways Authority actually I think it's
page 13 the highway authority concurs
with the parking analysis of the
transport statement and consider
sufficient parking supplies available
within a reasonable walking distance of
the site so obviously as the name
implies that in the Highways Authority
and experts but I do bear in mind the
fact that you're the local member and
you going pass there on a regular basis
so it's just a bit of it took a bit a
bit of a quandary as far as a Lupin is
it highest authority in my view on
gullible so you're basically disagreeing
with them well I know they're wrong
because the way that Street and Church
Street and Stratford Road are are used
actually is people do not park along
those roads they treat is if there are
double yellow lines there already the
point was made by the speaker on behalf
of Tesco's that a number of residents do
park along Stratford Road they do indeed
but when they do they park either
absolutely on the pavement or straddling
the pavement why did they do that it's
because they've got comments
they know that if they park on that side
of the road completely on the road they
won't cause an obstruction if you if you
took verbatim what's in the report and
you parked cars along Church Street and
Stratford Road the length of areas a B C
and D you would cause well you would
reduce the flow of traffic to one lane
in either not in either direction one
lane because the road cannot take for
car for vehicles of the breast it is an
ETS of nonsense and the evidence is on
the ground people in ships and the good
people of Shipton know this and that's
why they don't park there
thank you I just thought I'd give you
the opportunity sir
and thank you okay so fielding you did
this again to me I don't know the piece
you're referring to if you if you were
looking at the garage that is parking
that's private parking it used to be
officers it's been converted into
residences and the parking on that front
is for and the residents yes that that
block II thought that one that one to
the left of the red curve that are the
the development site that that is
private parking for it's between the
building on the corner the next corner
is now called the white horse and in the
properties that lie back
we're officers listeners officers and on
their resident said that's all parking
for the white horses it I think it
shared it might be shared between the
white horse and and the residents so
we've got a magistrate
there are people who live in those
residents as an anti force and there are
people who use those the people who use
the white horse typically arrive by by
car maybe right
I think we've exhausted that one I think
Ken Starr Harvey you're free to go thank
you right we'll now move on to points of
clarification then I think then what we
wanted to we seem to be concentrating on
party such as size of the footprint is
it much larger than creating fees in
freezer units and the noise from I don't
think I've got a slide that shows you
the comparison footprint to to the
ground floor units based I think it is
it is larger than the existing building
but obviously you have the reduction
because you no longer have the canopy to
the front of the site so in terms of
overall built development as a footprint
it's less if you take away whatever
but but but in with I believe it's a
little wider
I haven't to hand and I could I could
find it but I'd need to get the two
plans to compare what the difference is
okay bear with me a moment sure we do
have a plan showing the original
footprint of the building which states
from the the very first planning
permission for redevelopment to the site
in 2011 I would say yes so the work the
workshop is is sorry I'm confused by the
question so that the proposed tesco site
is is marginally wider than the existing
workshop but in terms of its
relationship to the previous consent
it's exactly the same footprint I was
pre as was previously proposed ourselves
yes yes and and in terms of freezes and
the like the plan is and if you can just
let me come out of this one again
that's external plant area shown there
so it is to the rear up first floor
level environmental health were
consulted on the application and
originally just wanted some additional
information submitted that has been
submitted and they've considered that
they're happy with the details of the
plant that have recommended a condition
that the noise levels from that plant be
controlled which is what I've detailed
in the update sheet so that there would
be specific noise levels from that plant
conditioning all started review plant
equipment according to environmental
health are happy that subject in the
meeting a level which could be monitored
and controlled that that they're
satisfied it wouldn't cause such a
street noise nuisance tested unit and
just then to to reiterate that point the
planning permission that has been
approved is for a similar level of
development and similar parking
provision to the one this current
application this day same base with Jim
I'm picking sober that the parking for
the residents that the flat so I mended
the impression whenever we grant an
application for a resident is two
parking spaces per resident per flat per
house upon whenever here we've only got
three if you know if when they come back
after a day's work
they can't park outside their house I'm
going up to Telegraph Street car park
now that's nice monument but I thought
we had to give car parking spaces to the
to a resident
I think in this situation we've got the
development requirement SPD which as
part of it part a sets out parking
guidance and so yes for two red flats it
would be two parking spacing is
recommended and then in addition to that
you would have the parking spaces
recommended for a retail unit the amount
of parking provision proposed is clearly
less than what that would add up to in
total I think there's a reality as to
how much parking you could genuinely fit
on this site with any form of
development at all in balance in that
and the developer has transportation
have recommended a management plan which
could include how that parking is
allocated so certainly at this moment in
time Tesco's haven't said that parking
would be allocated to a resident or to
or to the store and I think there's
probably scope if countess's felt that
that's what they wanted to do to perhaps
say that how they would like that
parking allocated and for that to be
enshrined into the the condition or at
least a note to guide how that condition
is then discharged but fundamentally the
parking hasn't changed from the previous
so mr. chairman there yeah just so it's
a speaking of chesco said it's up for
grabs isn't it really as proposed that
moment so certainly they haven't said
these three parking spaces will be
allocated to the residents or they will
be allocated to the shoppers in this
look I guess it's up for debate
to some extent whether you consider
there's merit in specifically allocating
them to one or the other or whether
actually having a free fair approach
would be beneficial yeah I thought it's
one of those situations that we had to
give added work car park is basically
that's what I felt okay
Joey [ __ ] clarify that point for just
in terms of the the new parking
standards there is a there is a parent
of a sentence which is included within
the parking standards for residential
development which states parking
standards should be taken as a starting
point and each proposed scheme will be
assessed accordingly so it's it's not
necessarily a fixed there is there is a
scope within that and each case is
assessed on an individual basis in this
case we have the we have the situation
where we've accepted a lower parking
standard under the 2014 application
there was an earlier planning permission
for the redevelopment to this site in
2011 which was a slightly more intensive
site that had a larger number of
residential units again with with a very
very limited parking provision that was
the very one with I think five flats
over council bonds respective parking
thank you go on every I need some way to
talk about what some talk that it has to
be 24-hour parking to be available in a
closed area complying like that or have
they changed I think so the the
development requirement SPD doesn't
specify it just says X amount of spaces
available it doesn't say for a certain
amount of time and again I think you
know it's up for debate whether you
consider there's some flexible approach
or or how you would progress with that
but but certainly the the policy doesn't
enshrine how that should operate
so our judgment has to come down to how
much weight is on the principle of the
previous development that has been
agreed and the current SPD which has
since been developed between a
comprehensive impact assessment in the
National Planning Policy study this is
an InTown this is an incentive
development so that the neighbourhood
plan which has also been adopted since
the previous consent was in place
outlines this site has been as part of
the town center in addition this is a
small scale retail unit so no a retail
impact assessment hasn't been carried
out but it wouldn't have needed to have
been under that policy so there in the
piper building - 2300 hours Monte Sunday
- there is to be restricted from 7
o'clock to 2100 100 hours Monday through
Saturday and 10 o'clock till 4:00 p.m.
and Sundays and bank holidays I'm just
to clarify those conditions are a direct
translation from the previous approval
having spent seven hours yesterday
discussing
being out in closing hours and music and
noise and people sleeping across away
from venues people leaving this place
there's going to be noise a car parking
doors are you trying to ask it was sort
of a question they're cancelling are you
trying to say
perhaps the impact on the neighbors with
these obviously environmental health
being consulted on the application they
were consulted on the previous
applications there was an application to
so that the 2013 application approved in
2014 had slightly reduced opening hours
there was then a variation application
put in and it was agreed at that point
but those hours were acceptable and
environmental health haven't changed to
an objection or considered that there
should be an objection in relation to
this application with these proposed
hours so to that effect yes it has been
considered so again just a dent on -
like Victoria are these opening hours
restrictions mentioned here comparable
to other applications to existent or
they've done on a case-by-case basis yes
our view is that this is a town centre
locations we don't consider these fees
as unreasonable environmental health of
have raised no objection and material
consideration - to this application is
the existing use of the site albeit
closed this is a workshop and petrol
filling station with a with the with the
shop as far as we can identify there
were no restrictions on hours of opening
or hours of operation so we are a
workshop would would normally be a car
workshop would normally be a noise
generator in its own
own right within the markets queries so
are they getting preference this not
we've got two kinds filter we've got to
stick to the site I'm afraid I think the
officers have explained it's a ten cent
to site it's been explained that
environment haven't been consulted so I
think that to a extent defer that I
think as a fair question right I think
we've exhausted the officers my
questions and should we move on to the
debate we couldn't find any way to park
we have to go and park in the district
council car park themselves to hang our
veggies in the mirror so that we didn't
get charged what concern is back
entrance which you can see that appears
to be addressed it is very similar to
the one that has been approved and
although it's unfortunate that
environmental health county council all
don't object I think we're stuck in the
situation which we were before
that as far as I'm concerned then it has
to move forward what's the middle thanks
Michelle
I'm a little bit concerned about the
parking for the rest and somebody I know
we've been through that but I again I
feel that people are dropping into this
task of Express
coming up one meeting place I'm talking
to his Tesco Express they won't find
anywhere to park and again that we get
on the double yellow and taking a chance
it's it's a difficult one I'm I know
with their highways being said they
haven't got a problem with it and
Victoria obviously hasn't got a problem
with it I've got a slight problem with
it I think it's gonna create more
problems along there I might visit this
site myself that last week and parked in
the next door into where they've
residents out I could look around not
too sure about this one chairman I'll
reserve judgment call me thank you
sorry cancel adjourned about that one
for me it is it's a problem but the
material considerations if it goes to
you know most an appeal would be that
not only was there a previous applicant
previous permission given for exactly
the same area but that there was a
garage there before which also caused
those same problems so the only only
other thing is given that the county
councils give no objections to highways
is what way to do we give to the they've
developed the SPD since I that seems to
me that the problem that probably the
original permission should not have been
given but it is a material consideration
that it was given
Thank You councilman and from my
perspective there's a couple of things
and when that ship is an NDP was
completed there already was a permission
on this site already so there's nothing
showing up in there NDP that said this
shouldn't have happened there's no
mention of it and to say now that their
NDP says we can't do this it doesn't sit
well with me that he already had
permission and was included in the NDP
and now saying that it can't go ahead so
on that basis despite all that I mean 80
percent of this conversations mean about
parking I would be able - to support the
officers on this because of its involved
with its previous involvement in NDP's
and having been cleared okay
so till the last
my feeling is similar to that they have
had it in the NDP and didn't raise a
comment however anomaly that Tesco's
didn't produce somebody who could talk
about the design the other sides of it
all we were dealing with was transport
but yet it's going to be a building
there that could cause other problems
I'm going to abstain on this one I think
that's all I can say
I noticed the SPD was mentioned by
component councillors and the offices
didn't mention that if we remind you to
approve and
we haven't gone through the votes there
was a possibility of either putting a
note or a condition for those three
spaces to be allocated for parking for
residents so again as part of that I'm
just bringing that back in to remind
members about that as well so okay so
doing it
could we have some guidance on that
please yes in terms of the allocating
those spaces to to residents it's
something that we we both feel would
justify we don't obviously know the
response from Tesco's from it but yes it
would it in all cases this can't comply
with the parking standards but the
parking standards as I've said for both
commercial and for residential do have
this caveat in that depending on
individual circumstances there is
flexibility around them this is a town
center location it's shown is town
center within the NDP there is an
expectation I think within my reading of
the NDP is there isn't an expect and an
expectation that all all sites will be
provided with a full parking on-site
provision there is parking in the
locality there are similarities in terms
of the previous planning permissions the
residents parking zone was in place in
2008 but that's been confirmed by the
highway authority so when the 2011
planning permission was granted and when
the 2014 planning permission were
granted we have - we had a constant we
have a constant in terms of the parking
availability and that is a material
consideration to this application
appreciate the reference to the parking
standards but the other factors are
constant with specific reference to a
conditional how that would work I'm
afraid I'm going to sit on the fence and
not give you a specific
response because the policy doesn't say
anything in particulate to my mind and
there could certainly be a note are
they'd sort of directing how you would
wish that management condition to to be
discharged or what should be included in
that you could allocate it entirely to
residential my concern with that would
be that what a resident isn't parking
there because they're at work you would
have a free forecourt and whilst that
can be managed that might frustrate the
situation more so it may be that you
wish to allocate it as a residential
parking just in the evening or something
along those lines but but perhaps if you
if you reminded two to give us some
guidance as to what could be put in a
note to help us discharge condition if
that's what you reminded to do then
perhaps that's the way forward two
points one is that this is going on
after people have returned home so
there's going to be a problem with the
parking the other is that we have in the
past given permission for developments
of conversion of flats and things along
this along Telegraph car park and
basically the argument has always been
where are people going to park their
cars so we're gonna have a lot more cast
to a park and I know Krita saying was
very excited about all that so
somebody's going to abstain caterpillar
you've got a lot of points there could I
just ask one more question which is
could there be any any requirement that
the residents are given free car parking
in the public car park or residence
permits is that something that could be
done or is that completely outside
planning
so caps the bonds well now I did start
and I'm concerned parking is a problem
but it looks as though the rules
hilarious and unfortunately in any way
forward is for me to propose the
application got the opposition see here
he goes he stopped with over there
tonight they're quite happy with the
dish customers been going on what's a
night yeah saying what the problem
before was that it wasn't a 24 hour
carpal bone we need to make sure
thirties I believe it is now just like
it clear then I think when we discussed
it there was a possibility that we put
an item that it became residents parking
that at night but again we haven't got
any indication of what the definition of
night was already evening we say from
six o'clock all beautiful between force
wouldn't it David I think just thinking
about it I think we are yeah I think the
note or condition might not be
enforceable or precise enough and so on
no I'm sorry concerned about that so
we've had a proposal from catch the
Barnes to go over the officers
recommendation to approve the
application is that right caster Barnes
cancer Junod you're no second yeah with
the extra conditions in the update sheet
this is three negative conditions so you
guys three laughing no lighting details
the finished cup into the return garage
wall and the first floor retail space
should be sorry to be you so on in
connection with the ground floor retail
space so these operate is one retail
unit think that was right we've had a
proposal on a second as a second for the
application to be granted ask for the
officers recommendation should we go to
the vote all those in favor for those
against should we just make it clear
again all those in favor all the green
to the officers recommendation as per
the proposal broadcaster bonds and
seconded case of OG okay so Junod and
those against and there's no abstentions
so committee resolves to grant
application 17 / 0 1 9 2 0 fu oh thank
you move on to the next item on the
agenda which is urgent business don't
I'm happy I'm right thank you very much
all right now close the meeting
at all the urgent business business was
the power you said to write down you
should have kept quiet